Hi.
So, um,
plan for today.
I'm going to write a little bit on that
article,
check a couple of experiments, do a
couple small things. Uh, I am getting
ready to
head out of here, spend a few days in
Florida, and then go to Palo Alto.
So, uh, pretty much the main thing over
the next few weeks, got a couple
articles to put out. I've got a few
things to make sure we're working on our
servers. have a few different research
projects that we're
in a good spot with.
And uh we will uh so yeah, we'll we'll
have like probably a pretty chill
bit of time, but I still want to keep
streaming and I still want to like go
off some of the things I'm working on
here. Let me grab this.
We had a little bit of an interesting
morning here,
I guess. uh that got seen finally saw
some of the RL stuff. I know he's been
like doing RL things here and there and
uh he saw some of the recent stuff. So,
uh yeah, thanks for the uh the
endorsement, man.
It's a very nice bit of growth.
Welcome, Mag.
All right, so here's what we are uh
we're going to do. I am pull up a reream
first of all.
And I think we're going to check the
experiments
just to see if I I did anything. I kind
of forget if I had stuff running. I
think I had like a neural MMO run going.
And then after that
Okay. So, I guess we'll see if this is
more stable.
Uh, basically, I reduced the learning
rate. And it doesn't look like that
changed literally anything.
Like, they're basically the same exact
thing. And we'll see if this crashes or
not.
I guess there is. If we look at this
right here,
there's like a very very slight
difference in perf, but it's almost
negligible.
Yeah, that's got to be like negligible,
right? I guess it kind of slows. No, you
know, there is a difference. So, with
the lower learning rate, look at this.
You see that?
It actually doesn't do anything
for 10 billion steps.
Isn't that funny?
So, it just does flat and then this.
That's kind of cursed.
Well, we'll see if it's stable or not.
And we'll see if this like jumps up or
not. Whatever.
But yeah, it's only 640 bill that it's
supposed to run for, right?
That's a soda mo model either way.
Okay, I'm good with that for now.
I got all sorts of people messaging me
now from uh
those tweets.
Let me let me set a couple quick things
up so that I can actually reply to stuff
effectively throughout the day. And then
I think what we're going to do is we're
going to write on the quick start guide
a little bit today. So, if you guys are
interested in helping uh shape
the learning material that I'm putting
out because I don't do a ton of this
content. I really don't do a ton of
educational content. So, if you want to
help shape this little bit and make it
as useful as possible to you, you'll be
able to do that today.
I just have to enter one one thing here
guys and I'll get started.
Cool. So, uh, let me see if there's any
of It's like because there's like this
massive blow up now that I'm just
getting because of all of the, uh, the
new stuff, which is Good.
I got yet seen looking through hyper
pram stuff as well.
right. I I did not intend to just like
start stream and be handling DMs, but
let me at least like
it would be cool to have him uh doing
some drone stuff around with us. It
would be fun.
right.
People are noticing has been looking for
cool projects for a while. Yeah, man. I
hope so.
It It definitely helps. It's like It's
very cool because we get more open
source stuff. we help the clients and
also it does actually generate us like
additional inbounds on clients as well
which which helps because I would like
to make this thing uh like a larger
private lab so we can get more servers
and fund more stuff.
where we left this thing off, I think I
was five sections through.
I'm trying to think how I want to
position this.
So,
for new people here, does this sort of
plan
make sense or is there uh stuff you'd
want to see in here that's different?
So, quick summary.
advice so far. And this is linked to all
sorts of articles in here.
Super basic intro that has you build the
simplest possible working thing.
Some pretty accessible fundamentals.
A still pretty dang simple but at least
kind of cool environment that you build.
start feeding in a little bit of the
fundamental knowledge, some stuff about
how our infrastructure works, some stuff
about general RL, and then by here
you're doing like a real Contact.
Little the cobwebs out of my head a
little bit here.
I have like multiple DM threads that I
was expecting to like calm down.
Whatever. So, puffer algo article.
Let's go grab these. Let me see. What
did I actually write? because I have
like a few different things.
I think this is the main. Are there any
of these that I want to link otherwise?
Oh, there isn't a three. It's just Yeah.
Okay.
It was the trailer. Cool. That's fine.
These two are the same. That's why I've
been confused and stuck here cuz it
doesn't make any sense.
I I honestly think that these last ones
I kind of just wrote these at the end of
the stream and uh they don't like the
ordering and the sequencing isn't good.
I think this is fine.
We have you build something. That's
cool. We give you a very accessible blog
post. It's a pretty short read.
Make you read a little bit of code and
build some more stuff.
I think that we don't give them this
infrastructure here.
I think I move this down
and I give these articles
here.
Okay.
You know, I
I don't like that I'm giving people the
PO paper this early. Almost, right? I'm
kind of stuck,
actually. Let me ask you guys about
this. Okay. Let me let me ask you guys
about this. What What do you do about
this? Okay, so I've linked a couple blog
posts at this point, even just one that
aren't mine. Like I linked Carpathy's
post, right? But pretty much the rest of
all this material comes from me.
So
like I don't want to make the guide just
like, hey, read all of my other stuff
and you're good, right?
Like I want to link you to external
formal resources. But the problem is my
stuff is literally way easier to
understand than everything else that's
out there. Okay? Like let me show you
the difference.
This is my where's my description of PO.
Okay? I just say yeah this is just
vanilla policy gradient with general
generalized advantage estimation which
is just a fancy exponential reward
discounting with a value function
baseline and it adds policy clipping.
Like I give you like a three sentence
description that's like this is what PO
is and how it works for the most part.
All right? And that's like 80%
of the actual intuition behind the
algorithm is these three or four
sentences. And if you actually look, I
have more detailed content on my
algorithms and stuff. But then the
problem is as soon as I link you
to like an actual formal paper, okay,
this is the difference.
They're going to hit you with all this
crap.
All right? And the thing is when I read
this, like I know that none of this [ __ ]
even matters. Like this doesn't even
matter. You can ignore this. This is
just a poorly written version of a
different formula. And then this is like
this is like using fancy math to explain
something that is basically two
sentences in plain English with exactly
the same meaning. Like
I don't want to like confuse the hell
out of new people to RL because some
people are going to come in with a math
background where yeah this is easy and
some people are going to be like what
the hell is this?
And the thing is you do not need to
understand this to understand the RL. So
I don't actually know what to do with it
can be referred to the materials.
Yeah, exactly. So but Spencer, this is
this is kind of my goal here is to And
also, hey, how's it going? I hope you're
doing all right with the Texas floods. I
don't know if those are anywhere near
you. Um,
I pretty much like I'm trying to drip
feed in content,
but like I don't want people to say
like, "Ah, don't worry about it. You
don't need to learn it." You do need to
learn the stuff at some point, but like
I kind of want to make sure that people
have already seen, okay, I can build
some I already can build awesome stuff.
Now, let me maybe go to learn some of
the formalism.
Um,
Also, I got us a bunch of cool inbound,
so working on that.
We're at
82 as well.
in moving.
I'm building much more educational and
so do I.
A lot of the questions that you ask,
right, the thing is like, okay, how do I
magically know the answer to everything,
right?
It's because I actually h like I
understand the actual fundamentals,
right?
Stuff should be referenced.
I have that in the quick start guide.
I'm kind of trying to give people an
order like instead of like reference
this, reference that, I'm trying to give
people a very like a pretty script, a
pretty strict prescribed do this, do
this, do this, read this, do this, read
that. Now you know RL, congratulations.
Okay, let me see if I can put it further
down at least.
The problem is I like I don't like that
we have no references
like outside of carpath is blog.
the CS classes aren't going to help with
the papers.
The thing is the main the main
algorithmic paper it looks like this
like relative to how simple the idea is.
It's a super dense paper. Like actually,
as far as RL papers go, this isn't even
that bad. But like relative to how
utterly simple
the poor algorithm is.
Like this is a lot.
Like I don't want to link people that.
But the thing is I can't
I can't link you the article.
I don't think anybody has a good blog
post on PO either.
Do I need to make one? I really don't
want to.
Let me see if I can link people a
section of it or I can at least tell
people how to read it in a way that's
not going to be this painful cuz I think
you do need to at least see where like
that there like this exists but I think
you need to not suffer.
There's the thing is fundamentally
there's no way you can genuinely
understand RL without being able to
interact with the literature.
What?
Yeah, there's an im there's a difference
between an avocado and a hand gun as
well. What's your point?
Okay. What is the optimal point to start
interacting with the literature?
built a couple small projects.
The thing is custom networks is not even
in this.
So custom networks is covered by the
background material like CS231N. You
should know how to build custom
networks.
It's definitely at least after you've
built like one substantial project.
I think I just need to prefix it with
some stuff.
I think I need to give him the PO paper
relatively early, but with the caveat
that like
the paper's a lot simpler than what is
actually presented.
Hey, boxing. What are we trying to do
here? So, I'm trying to figure out how I
can make this article
actually good for people learning RL.
The point is to understand PPO. I don't
think you can avoid back and forth.
Yeah, exactly.
The thing is it's like you can't really
implement PO
like implementing PO is not a short
exercise because like the very small
details for which there isn't really any
theoretical basis matter a lot in terms
of whether it's actually going to work
or not.
I don't feel there's a place where they
distilled the high into it. Yeah,
exactly.
It's clipped. It's clipped. It's clipped
updates on policy gradients so that you
don't go too far off policy.
The generalized advantage estimation is
a better as a better form of reward
discounting than bullet
We give you a build section.
This is like a few hours worth of
reading.
And then I think you kind of have the
background to do something.
quite a bit more substantial and you
should hopefully have enough intuition
not totally mess stuff up
very relieving actually I opened PO saw
the equation was like oh okay much more
adequate yeah so this is the problem max
and I'm trying to make this guide
actually pretty well just ex like just
for you in this sense. Um
like it's exactly for you in that case
cuz like this type of stuff sucks and
like I know what this is because I've
seen this specific notation and this
specific equation a bunch of times but
if I open a random RL paper that has
like even the exact same thing or
something very similar in a different
notation, it will take me a couple hours
to figure out what they're saying. Uh
sometimes it's because the math is
actually very precise and very helpful
and it's just complicated. But most of
the time it's just because researchers
like writing math for the sake of
writing math.
The actual math that you need to know.
Okay. So it helps to be able to
understand notation enough such that if
you spend a couple hours you can figure
out what they're actually trying to do
with all the math, right? Like that is
helpful.
Um, but outside of that,
the knowledge you need for RL is the
same as the knowledge you need just to
understand the fundamentals of deep
learning in general. Need to know what a
partial derivative is. Need to know what
a matrix is. That's it.
to understand all the mathy stuff for
sure at some point but not starting
point. The thing is you actually can
build some crazy cool RL stuff before
you even understand it. Um the thing is
it the point of really getting into the
RL literature is if you want to actually
help us advance the core algorithmic
research that's the like that is the
point at which you really need to
understand this stuff it helps generally
and like I don't know if you watch me
debugging people's stuff in
reinforcement learning like we'll always
have contributors that'll show me a
thing and I'll just go like oh yeah do
this and and it'll instantly work. That
comes from a very strong grasp of
fundamentals plus years of practical
experience. But like you do need it
eventually, but like I don't write stuff
this way, right? I do not write this
type of stuff. I will write the exact
same content, the exact same
information, but not like this if I can
avoid it.
The one exception I did do this for the
protein blog post but that was because I
was directly referencing another very
heavy mathematical work. So like I did
this
I did this thing right
this is the background on the algorithm
and then I said okay this is our new
function here
but that's about as much as I did and
the pro the uh the carbs paper that
protein is based on is arguably much
heavier mathematically than um the PO
paper but the idea is not that
complicated Hell.
Okay.
So, that's the first five.
started with five sections done and we
have five slightly better sections done.
I guess we have this paragraph as well
that we're left over with.
research applications, infrastructure,
right? Are going to be three of them.
I can make the last three sections a
choose your own adventure.
Me grab more coffee real quick. So, I
know the last three sections are going
to be advanced infrastructure,
um, going to be advanced
research, like how to actually get into
research,
and then applications.
Oh, we have a fair few folks on YouTube
today. Welcome everybody.
Uh yeah, if you guys are actually new or
relatively new to RL and you have ideas
on things that you would like to see
presented in this guide, that's why I'm
streaming writing. Like I wouldn't be
streaming writing otherwise, right?
So please tell me that's why I'm
streaming it. Let me get coffee.
The YouTube chat is working, right?
Because I don't think I've seen a single
message from YouTube.
There's a message that just didn't show
up.
Starang.
I don't know why it does that.
Now it shows up. Oh, was it just now?
Okay.
I read the TRPO one and it is intuitive
if you've done convex opt. Okay. Yeah,
but here's the thing. like if you've
done convex opt then I don't have to
worry about the math side at all and I
can just tell you go read all these
papers right and then the thing that we
have to figure out is the engineering
side
I'm writing a guide that's like people
start at different points right a lot of
people are going to know either
engineering or math but not both
teach us RL from basics to advance
Yeah, but what's that mean? Sarang,
right? Like that's what I'm trying to
figure out like what gaps I'm missing
and stuff. People have not done convex
opt. Oh, I have a fun story about that.
So, when I got to Stanford, they uh they
brought us all into, you know, a big
auditorium and the president gave us
this like long- winded speech about how
uh Stanford students don't know how to
fail, right? like you guys have never
failed at anything and you don't know
what that's like. So I I took that as a
challenge. So uh my winter semester I
enrolled in a full course load uh plus
two graduate courses upper div graduate
courses one of which was convex
optimization with Steven Boyd which is a
notoriously hard class that has a
24-hour long final. The final is written
to take you 24 hours and you have 24
hours to do it.
So yeah, I did not pass that class. Uh,
no, there was not a snowballs chance in
hell, but I did learn a bunch of cool
stuff from it.
Engineering is important. Math can be
done by people like you. I'm not a good
mathematician at all,
I took the 24hour final right as well. I
think I might have gotten like one
question mostly correct.
It's actually one of my favorite classes
though because like
the one thing I learned from convex opt
that was really useful uh Steven Boyd
gave a great introduction to parto
optimality and sensitivity analysis and
I have used that everywhere ever since.
It was like the one really accessible
piece of that course.
also the problem with like the problem
with getting too theoretical about a lot
of this stuff, right, is you write this
beautiful formula for constrained
optimization with TRPO or whatever and
then it just doesn't work,
right? It just doesn't work.
I remember that course was so funny.
Boyd said um he said that he used to
make his final open book and open other
professors. So you used to be able to go
ask other professors for help with his
final. And he said that he did this to
screw with other professors because they
could not take his exam.
This is the reason I lean towards
heavier engineering is because basically
I was very practical with like all right
what is the thing I need to know in
order to make the thing I want to work
work and it was mostly engineering.
At the time I finished his course, I
thought SGD was trash and Newton's
method is the way to go. Yeah. You know,
and then like I spent the next several
years thinking that all optimization
research was kind of just trolling
because really not much came out of
optimization research for a long time,
but then Muan came out of left field and
ended up being a huge huge improvement
for RRL stuff. So like there's actually
legitimate stuff in uh optimizer
research.
You just can't have anything that's like
quadratic or n login in um in terms of
the number of weights cuz like obviously
right
Did you take his course at Stanford out
of curiosity
off to debug poly touring machine. Good
luck with that. Holy, I think that's a
new record. We have that's at least 15
people on the stream. Hey everyone,
welcome.
We are uh
trying to finish this guide today so
that you all will actually have
educational material on RL. I don't do a
ton of educational material, but it's
been highly highly requested. So, I'm
trying my best here.
We're kind of uniquely positioned where
like
RL's actually really easy to get into
with Puffer, but then bridging the gap
between how easy it is in Puffer versus
like how you interact with everything
outside of Puffer is kind of hard.
Welcome, Grant.
Can you give us a glimpse of a prequel
article just to Yeah. So,
there are a few of them.
There are if you look on the docs here
or the blog
there's this quick start guide which
just has fundamental terms some
perspective and some things that I use a
lot. This is a lot of about like
intuition and how to view the field.
Okay, this is a lot and this links you
to resources. This like gives you a lot
of good resources to read but it doesn't
actually say read this then read this
then read this then read this. doesn't
give you the introduction like that
which is what I'm doing now. And then
the other article that I think will
launch concurrently with this is we have
uh my programming advice which applies
to people who've also been programming
for several years. But just pretty much
if the way that you see me writing code
on stream looks weird, you should read
this. Um and then there's how to learn
ML. This is actually really short
because Stamford CS231N is really really
good and it's free online and if you
just take that one course which is very
accessible you're kind of good to go.
The only other thing that I added here
which is very important is because you
have to read papers in ML like you have
to read papers. You must um I added this
section here which is I think sheds a
lot of light on why papers are the way
that they are and should make it a lot
easier for people to get into reading
papers.
Thanks. Yeah.
I mean cuz other than that, right,
some of the terms welcome to spinning
up. So, spinning up is okay. Uh,
spinning up is pretty good. The problem
with spinning up is it's like 10 times
too much math and like the code sucks.
So, it's really like the math is good,
but you don't need that much math to get
started. If you have a strong math
background already and that helps you,
then go for it. Uh, but if you have like
either a more balanced background or a
more software heavy background, it's not
going to help and the code sucks.
So, that's tough.
Have you tried SACE?
Uh, I think people really only use SACE
in robotics these days because their
simulators are slow.
I haven't actually seen like good
evidence for SACE over anything else.
The thing that people do uh which is
really crappy is they always use steps
for their Xaxis. So even if one is 10
times slower than the other, they still
use steps. Like they treat data as holy
and like you can never get any more data
even though you can.
So I don't think there's much to SACE.
I'd have to look more into it. It's also
there's problem with discrete spaces
which is annoying.
So I PO has been really good, but then
our version of PO is like our new
algorithm is a lot better than PO as
well. And the key is that it's fast. I
can guarantee you that nothing beats
what we have here on speed. Like on raw
speed, ours is the fastest. If you want
to get into sample efficiency, that's
kind of the open area of research that I
have to look into next. Uh the
literature out there at the moment is
very very bad and the reason for that is
obvious, right? So if you're doing this
very sample efficient learning where
your experiments are really slow, you
can't run a lot of experiments.
So you're kind of just screwed.
But my hope is that what we can do is we
can take like the off policy algorithms,
we can run them in the very high data
availability regime and see if the off
policy algorithms do better when you
give them a ton of data than on policy
or if they're kind of the same. And then
when you crank up the data reuse, we'll
see if they diverge and if actually you
can use a lot more compute to get a lot
better results or not. Like good
controlled experiments kind of just
don't exist for this stuff.
Let's say that the last three of these
are going to be reserved for
infrastructure, right? research
and applications.
What other two things do I give people
before then?
Oh, you know what it is? You know what I
need to give people at this point? It's
core stuff,
right?
Like let's say that this is going to be
like specialty
infrastructure
and this is going to be like
I think we're not actually going to
stick Impala on here.
And Paula is actually kind of
There any multi- aent? Well, yeah,
there's going to be
Are there other papers I should
recommend people?
Trying to think of the papers.
I have a big project I'm working on and
could use your knowledge or help. Sure.
What is it?
I think what we do is we link all of
these
and unlike the original, we actually
give reasons why you read these
I don't want to link anybody any of my
own papers to be honest. I kind of hate
all my papers.
Are there any that I think are kind of
good?
Not really at all. Right. Is there a
neural MMO 3 paper?
No, there isn't. Right. I didn't write
one.
I'm trying to think if there are other
papers that I really think like that
should really be included.
Where was the original one? Is it only
on
Hey, Muhammad. Welcome. Your chat does
work.
I think this is probably the one to
suggest people, right?
Project details
only take one or two minutes to build.
Hang on.
Let me see. I'm looking. What? You're
Yeah, I'm looking at it.
Yeah, if I have a dolearn function that
works on literally anything, then you've
assumed a conclusion,
right?
There's not a single system in existence
that works that way either. Like
you can't just tell an LLM to do that,
for instance, and have it work. It'll
just kind of spin its wheels and do
nothing.
can't send links in chat. That's
YouTube, Muhammad, not me. Just tell me
what to Google or whatever if you want
to link me something. YouTube just bans
links and I don't think there's an
option to disable that. They do it to
prevent bots.
Yeah, you can either tell me what to
Google or DM it to me on X or Discord.
This paper is very good for starter.
Definitive guide to policy gradients.
Who wrote this thing?
BMPO is uh irre irrepable from what I
know.
Oh, you got to be kidding me that they
do this on page three,
dude.
Okay. So, like I could read this guide,
but like
yeah, no, this is going to make
everybody like not want to do RL unless
you really really like math. Like this
is just not
you do not need this level of math.
Like come on. This is not even like why
the [ __ ] do they have integrals?
Why have they replaced all the sums with
integrals for discrete problems? It's
like they tried to generalize it to
continuous time or whatever, but it's
not like it's fundamentally not.
Also, their policy gradient derivation
is like three times longer than the
usual one.
Yeah. If you told me you have to do this
amount of math to get to reinforce,
which is an algorithm that like doesn't
work. Yeah. Like I'd be out of here.
You want to know something that's kind
of funny? It's actually way easier for
me to train It's way easier for me to
train uh people with a basic systems
programming background for RL than it is
for me to train people with a strong
math background.
like if you have a strong math math
background, you can go read all the
papers and such, but RL is like it's so
heavily dependent on the engineering and
the implementations
that like that ends up being the main
bottleneck most of the time.
Took me a week to get past the first two
pages. Yeah. So, like that's not
productive at all. Like that's basically
academic hazing
because the material is not actually
that complicated. It's just they've
written it in the most complicated way
possible.
Dang, I need to learn.
Welcome, Nick. You're in the right place
to learn.
Everybody is in uh discord.gg/puffer.
We have literally brand new programmers
in there who have gotten to the point
that they're actually pretty good in RL
now.
And then of course the people who come
in with any sort of decent programming
background do very very well quite
quickly.
Okay, let's write the descriptions for
these.
Uh, there is suddenly like a gale
outside.
Yeah, the entire It's been raining for
10 minutes and the entire yard is
flooded.
think you should put more.
Thank you.
I haven't proof read it yet.
I'll put learning dexterity first
because it kind of pioneered the method.
Yeah,
I've got crazy lightning storm outside.
So, uh, if I disappear, that's why.
I have two free months and I'm looking
to contribute to Puffer AI. Where do you
suggest that I start? I have a good RL
and programming background. Depends on
your interests. So, there is heavy
research side stuff to do. there's heavy
infrastructure side stuff to do. Uh and
we're also looking for like applications
that are going to be useful in a number
of different areas. Okay. So on the
research side uh and this is a thing
that I'm going to start doing quite
soon.
We're going to have a big comprehensive
push to look through all of the 2020 era
and beforeish uh offline methods and see
if there is anything to offline methods.
They're kind of a mess and all the
research in the space is like kind of a
mess. So, we're probably going to have
to do some sort of version of Puffarel,
which is our main trainer that does that
stuff and like try out all the different
components and methods and see what
matters and what doesn't. That's one
huge thing on research side. Um, yeah,
there's stuff on hyperparameter tuning
and and other things in research as
well. I think that's the main big one
though. Let's see. Uh on the
infrastructure side, we want to actually
get close uh MFU to what is
theoretically possible, right? We want
to get uh close to one on that or 100,
however you define it. We haven't
actually done that stuff formally. As
fast as Puffer is, I think it could be
like two or three times faster yet.
Again, if we were to optimize that
stuff, there is also other related
infrastructure things we can do with
optimizing uh data transfer from CPU to
GPU. And then on the applications and
environment side, there are a couple
things there. Uh on one hand, like
there's the idea of designing probe
environments to help us with our
algorithmic research, but then there's
also the idea of like just going out and
finding hard problems in industry that
could be solved with fast sim and trying
to do that. That is also the way that
you get involved with the business side
of Puffer.
We do all of like all the research is
managed via the Discord. So,
discord.gg/puffer
if you're not already in there. And then
uh I also I mean I stream of course as
much as I can.
Both research and application look
interesting. I'll be more active on
Discord from now on. Yeah, I mean that's
the main thing. just like at me on there
and I usually catch everything unless
people are spamming my chats.
I am not a professor. I am technically a
doctor. I'm not a professor. You think
that current phones and laptops will be
so much better if they had local LMS
lava quantized versions developers could
just add useful features on top? Not
really.
Like, yeah, not really.
You'd have to come up with something
that that actually lets you do that's
interesting
cuz right now like the have a chatbot
assist like assistant everywhere thing
has really not been all that useful.
I I mean I don't even know if it does
anything if you have a good one, right?
Like if I give you 03 on a phone, does
that actually do anything
advisor and coach? it was the right
thing to tell me in the moment. Yeah,
the thing is that um the LLMs, they kind
of just lie half the time.
So
yeah,
they're very good at giving you coherent
sounding information that makes no
sense.
Like half the time you'll ask something
that you can just Google and it'll just
give you the wrong answer.
Advisers and especially coaches aren't
pure oracles of truth either. Yeah. No,
but this one's particularly bad.
I mean, I could see in a couple of
generations them being very useful, but
at the moment they kind of just aren't
Yeah, they just gaslight you. Exactly.
They're kind of bad.
Like honestly, everybody shits on
Perplexity, but I like the thing that
they actually tried to do.
I don't use this, and maybe I should,
but like uh is the effect of
counting rate in RL.
So, this thing actually gives you
citations for stuff
which like they're not very good, right?
These are really bad citations, but the
idea of having like this is where this
information came from. And I would
actually I would like it to have it so
that you can literally it would quote
the material from the specific source.
Like something like this is I think
closer to what I would want
because otherwise like the generations
are just crap. Like if this thing can go
find me this information out of like
textbooks and papers and stuff and say,
you know, here are these five different
like five different sources. They
present this information this way. I'd
be way happier rather than it just being
wrong.
Pull in search results. Yeah. So, they
pull in search results. They all do this
at this point, but then they get it
wrong.
Instead of retrieval augmented
generation, I'd kind of prefer
generation augmented retrieval.
What's Carpathy's plan with Eureka Labs?
ML only by LLMs.
No idea.
Sound like you're against LMs or feel
they're overrated?
No. I mean, I think LLMs are very good.
And I think that there's like a one in
three chance that LM solve everything.
They're just incredibly incredibly
overhyped right now, though. And it's
like 99% of the attention and resources
are on uh language models when it seems
like there's some pretty clear
fundamental problems that we're kind of
just all ignoring because that doesn't
help us raise money.
I do use LLMs in like a fair bit of my
work. I just don't like copy paste
blocks of generated code and I'm very
very careful when I use them as sources
for stuff because again half the stuff
is just wrong.
Why one and three?
My personal best probability estimate. I
don't know.
But do you think that's too high or too
low?
I mean it's the fact that like
humans are really really bad at
estimating exponential scaling. So like
it is possible that a lot of the things
that look like fundamental problems just
disappear as you continue to pour
billions of dollars into these things
and like the hardware also just gets
better. So maybe we just end up with
like a 10 trillion parameter model
that's just actually amazing.
Um
it we just we haven't really seen these
things work in any of the ways that like
intelligence needs to work though. Like
why the hell can't an LLM go teach
itself stuff, right?
Like any reasonably smart person can go
out and teach themselves something,
go learn quantum physics. All right, I
will come back several weeks later with
a decent knowledge of quantum physics.
But like it seems like the LLMs, it's
kind of just what you do in pre-training
and then you're stuck with that. And
there's not
these things don't like recursively
self-improve.
And most of the works I'm saying that
they do are like really really [ __ ]
Like for instance, I think some of the
stuff on like AI writing kernels is kind
of interesting, but it's not that the AI
is getting better at writing kernels.
It's that just kernels are a pretty
small constrained search space and
they're kind of just running like
exhaustive fuzzy search over kernels,
but then like it's not like the model's
actually getting better at writing
kernels such that once it does search a
bunch of times and writes a few good
kernels, it's going to just start
writing good kernels by default.
Like that's how an actual that's how a
low-level dev is actually like trains,
right? If you get a low-level dev and
have them write a few kernels, by the
time they're on their fifth or their
10th kernel, they're going to be way
better at
What do you think about Ken Stanley's
new thing? So, uh, Aar is on that. I
know. A car. I have not had the chance
to read that yet.
So, I'm going to have to go read that at
some point.
The things with LMS that we know is what
we primarily focus on. How fast they can
do things, how they can do things
repetitively.
That's not really the way I look at
things.
Like,
yay, we can maybe automate some
repetitive language tasks is not why I
get into RL or into AI in general.
Like I'm not really interested in just
like taking the capabilities of stuff as
it is today and like seeing the limited
things we can do with them.
I'm really more focused on how do we
advance research and how do we advance
the capabilities of AI in general.
I don't even know if I have three
sections here.
I don't see how that does anything more
than
like any of the free models now that are
faster.
Like you can literally get free models
without a subscription
right now that are better than Llama 3,
right?
Starting with deep RL courses on hugging
face and read the RL book. Wondering on
your opinions about this approach. Uh
welcome. First of all, it's decent. I
think you've kind of made stuff a little
bit harder on yourself than it needs to
be. The deep RL courses on hugging face
like the code associated with that is
like SB3 is not good at all. And uh the
RL book from Sutton and Bardau is good,
but it's like a lot of very heavy theory
that doesn't really show you
like how to actually make RL work.
So I would suggest to you like just
honestly go check out the stuff we're
doing in Puffer Lib now. There are a
whole bunch of articles and there is a a
quick start guide and there is like a
how to write your own environment. Like
most of the people that are getting into
RL, I just tell them to start writing
environments because there's no better
way to learn RL than to actually build a
problem yourself and then make RL solve
it from scratch and figure out like
you'll see all the things that can go
wrong with that as well. Um,
you'll also be starting out from a point
where our algorithms are actually pretty
good rather than most of the things in
those textbooks. Like they don't
actually work or they only work if you
spend three months tuning them.
The guide I'm working on right here is
actually going to point people to a
whole bunch of references. And uh I
think that some of the stuff in here
will be a very good entry point for you
as well.
What is it about ML and bad code? I mean
to be fair kind of all like code almost
everywhere is terrible. It's just that
it matters a lot more that your code
sucks in ML because you don't get an
error message. You just get an agent
that doesn't train properly and you
don't know why.
models are cursed to begin with and a
representation is fractured.
Representation is fractured.
Representation
There isn't really a representation to
begin with.
What contains logical
Yeah, I'd have to look.
You have to be careful with the neural
nets getting too small because when
neural nets get too small, you start
running into convexity problems
that don't exist in um larger models.
Like larger models can have saddle
points and can have uh poor
conditioning, but you don't really end
up with like local optima as a problem.
That's just not a thing. I have a
meeting in like 10. So, let me see what
we can do here.
I actually think we're going to just do
advanced topics.
Let's say for example I wanted to use
GPT4 to make apps for people just using
prompts
uh that kind of stuff like I think
almost works but doesn't really work at
the moment.
Yo, running into train test gaps and
drive end. Would a smaller model force
it to not be able to memorize?
Are you using all the maps, Spencer?
You should just use all the maps for
training.
Just use all the data.
Hey, welcome human.
I do have to run in a few minutes for my
uh first meeting today and I will be
back afterwards. We're going to finish
at least a first draft of the guide
today. That is the goal.
I tried. I got the full set. 10k maps.
100k is technically
Wait,
you have 100k though, don't you? Did you
train 100k or no? The beginner's guide
on RL completed. I'm working on it right
now. Programmer and ML have we have a
full draft of this
be. We have a full draft of this. It's
2K words.
It's got my advice on learning
programming and then all my advice on
learning ML.
Honestly though,
the ML section is very easy. Like the
most like go take CS231N. It is
available for free online with very good
lectures. And then the rest of my advice
basically just has to do with like how
to think about reading scientific papers
because once you take 231N
you know how to do basic projects. You
understand the basics of deep learning
and the only thing that you need to know
is how to teach yourself more stuff by
like reading papers effectively in
specific areas.
Oh, GPT or he heavily prompted Llama 3.
I don't think Llama 3 is any good, is
it?
I mean, either of these like the thing
is neither of these are going to work at
the moment, right? So like basically
there are a bunch of startups at the
moment like Replet and stuff where they
run language models in a loop in order
to build applications and they've like
hacked a whole bunch of stuff to try to
like make it sort of work. This type of
stuff will eventually work out of the
box I think on some of the big models
because it'll just be baked into the
capabilities. But for now, like you kind
of just can't do this stuff with base
models. And you can't do it with base
models and prompting either because the
problem is not that you don't have a
good prompt. The problem is
interactivity, right? It doesn't have a
feedback loop where it can build stuff
and deploy stuff and check errors,
right? That's the thing.
Okay, I have to uh I got to run for a
meeting
in just a second here. Uh so thank you
to folks for tuning in. I will be back
in probably like an hour, maybe less,
and we're going to finish this. So, if
you want to uh if you want to see me
finish this, and if you want to once I
finish this, like look through this with
me and figure out sections where things
are not covered that you'd want to see
covered in this, then you can join back
in. Uh otherwise, puffer.ai for all the
things. If you want to help me out for
free, for absolutely free, just start
the the uh GitHub repository. If you
want to get involved with development,
join the Discord. discord.gg/puffer.
Which models do you recommend? There
aren't models that do the thing that you
want to do at the moment that are not
thirdparty paid services. Uh Kamswis,
you can also follow me on X for more RL
content where I stream a whole bunch of
stuff and I post RL articles and such.
Oh.